and you know truly the senior vice
president of policy and practice at RFC
that we've just heard and Clare Lockhart
you are in your fellow at the Jackson
Institute for Global Affairs and
director and co-founder of the Institute
of state effectiveness which looks at
issues of accountability and governance
in fragile states and you are the
co-author with president uh Trapani who
is a LAN topologies by the way of the
book fixing and failsafe I work for a
pathology at the platform to do it
so examining in intersections with the
media on issues of security peace
building and development
you are so sturdy for for feedback and
responses and we are going to have them
a perhaps after with two interventions
from Stefan and Glenn Stefan which not
too sure she'll come here stand up her I
don't know oh thank you thing here would
be great right here Mike thanks so much
for the introduction and inviting me
here it's really exciting to be speaking
at Yale I wrap the organization I work
with the international refugee
assistance project was founded by law
students I was one of the cofounders
with our current director Becca Heller
and other students and we started it in
2008 and throughout the the time that
we've existed we've had such tremendous
support from the Yale community from dr.
Prabhu who spoke earlier from professors
of the law school from interpreters and
others who work or study here and so
it's really great to to be here I want
to talk today about first a little bit
about why I rep was started to respond
to some of the shortcomings of refugee
law it's also a little bit about why it
is a particularly terrifying time for
our clients right now
mainly refugees in the Middle East and
then third all talk about how as as
lawyers for our clients were responding
to some of these challenges so we we
started Iraq because some of us I have
worked in Egypt at a legal aid
organization another co-founder had been
in the US military and other had been a
journalist embedded in Iraq and we saw
that in addition to the tremendous
humanitarian needs medical needs
financial needs that former colleagues
or people who we were working with we're
facing there were also a lot of legal
challenges navigating the international
system and getting to safety when
programs existed refugee law is a
limited protection is limited to
individuals who have been persecuted to
of a well-founded fear of persecution on
account of a protected characteristic
race religion nationality membership in
a social particular social group or
political opinion and so seeking this
protection after you have sled from your
home country requires interacting either
if you're in the United States with the
the country government where we have a
system for a cylon that we talked
earlier or the panelists talked earlier
about some of the challenges of that
process and for a lot of refugees
overseas that similar process is set up
with the United Nations refugee agency
the UN High Commissioner for Refugees
where you have to register where you
have to go through a refugee status
determination before an international
adjudicator and here there are both
challenges in terms of the limits of law
because the adjudicator is trying to
assess whether you as an individual
meets that refugee definition whether
you have proven that you have a
well-founded fear of persecution whether
it is on account of a protected
characteristic and there are the
evidentiary challenges and the burdens
of showing that particularly because
most of the time the evidence is your
own testimony and when you
have fled from violence and the
initiative credibility that an
international adjudicator is looking at
things like whether you're consistent
whether you're detailed
are affected by trauma this can be a
really challenging interaction and
adjudication with very high stakes so we
saw that there was there was a need for
this type of assistance and we wanted to
provide that we thought as law students
we could help people navigate some of
that in the way that we were able to do
that was by partnering with lawyers in
in the US and partnering with
organizations overseas that helped us
identify clients in need and can work
with them for individuals who are
recognized as refugees there are other
shortcomings of refugee law namely that
the 1951 Refugee Convention which is
sort of the document that has been
signed by many countries around the
world lays out a set of rights that are
essentially allowing you to support
yourself and to have some type of safe
refuge until you can either return to
your home country or integrate
somewhere else but many of those the
main refugee hosting countries in the
region haven't signed on to the 1951
convention or they have signed on with
significant exceptions such that most
refugees are not able to work despite
the fact that they are you know there's
such incredible potential for the local
economies there for for themselves to to
support their families there's also not
in the 1951 convention any type of clear
requirement that a refugee have a
solution a durable solution is the term
that UNHCR uses so out of the the 21
million refugees around the world over 7
million or more in protracted refugee
situations they've been refugees for
more than than five years and
resettlement refugee resettlement which
we discussed is so limited such that
only about as of the last
stick that UNHCR published only about
wanting 200 refugees were able to be
resettled but at the same time that is
one of the programs that I rep assist
with it is incredibly important for our
clients who are the most vulnerable a
significant part of percentage of our
clients are LGBT refugees who face
ongoing daily persecution we also work
with women who are fleeing domestic
violence who are a continual risk and
for these individuals there isn't any
type of protection in local countries
they face imminent risks and so
resettlement is really the only option
for them these resettlement programs
that are set up at us or by other
countries are also challenging legal
processes you have the same types of
challenges that I mentioned before in
the UN processes and you also have very
challenging country specific laws the US
has laws related to terrorism related
inadmissibility which is a term that
lawyers use sometimes trade terrorism
related in this disability grounds that
are incredibly over broad and captured a
lot of refugees who do not in any way
fit the definition of a terrorist
because the the definition includes
individuals who were kidnapped and
washed the dishes for their kidnapper
would technically be considered a
terrorist because they supported a
terrorist organization and so there are
a lot of challenging legal barriers to
getting to safety we also work a lot
with u.s. affiliated Iraqis and Afghans
who worked with the US military and then
the burden is on them to produce all the
documentation that would allow them to
qualify to get to safety in the United
States despite the fact that the
contracting company may have closed or
their supervisors may have left and may
have gone to Panama in the Peace Corps
one of our former snappers
grace helped track down in Iraqi
supervisor in group several days before
the deadline to apply for a life-saving
visa and so this is the kind of
challenges that our clients face
now turning to why now is a particularly
terrifying time for our clients as I'm
sure you all we're have been following
the u.s. tried to ban our clients from
entering the US on January 27th the
administration signed the first
executive order it had several parts to
it broadly speaking there was a travel
ban on individuals from various Muslim
majority countries that that prohibited
them from entering this as the United
States there was also a suspension of
the refugee program for 120 days and
there were other provisions that were
meant to make admission more difficult
to to the US one of our clients who had
worked for the US for ten years in Iraq
with the US military was on a plane as
the executive order waiting to effect
when he arrived he had legal paperwork a
visa to enter the United States but
instead of being allowed to enter a JFK
he was put into handcuffs detained and
told that he would be sent back to Iraq
which is the the country where he had
fled and was conversing persecution so
this was a you know a devastating
executive order it was later rescinded
and a new one in went into effect on
March 6th or a rather was signed on
March 7 was scheduled to go into effect
that second executive order has been
challenged by I rap and others in the
courts and is currently suspended this
is really troubling for our clients for
a few reasons first the message it sends
to our clients that you are not welcome
that the u.s. is not you know no longer
a sort of beacon of refuge but rather
that you are not allowed to come into
our u.s. to the US the message to the
American people that is throughout the
executive order that refugees are
threats
there was a lot of great work done by
one of the the the clinics here to get a
bipartisan national security brief with
experts including heads of National
Security Agency is from both under both
parties under bolted several past
administrations saying that this was not
a rational response that this was not in
any way supported by the evidence that
individuals who were barred refugees and
immigrants from from these countries
were not a threat because we have an
assistance system that that that works
and finally the the message to allies in
the region to that the u.s. works with
that you're on your own that you know as
countries like Lebanon were one in five
individuals is is a refugee that that
the u.s. is not going to be a leader in
the humanitarian response our clients
are also incredibly concerned as a
terrifying time because of what was
mentioned before about the u.s. cutting
aid to individuals who are in countries
of first refuge the u.s. is the main
funder of the UN refugee agency about 40
percent of the budget so at the same
time that the door for the most
vulnerable cases is closing you have a
cutting of refugee aid at the same time
the main proposal by the u.s. is to
basically send individuals back to to
Syria for into what par you know terms
of safe zones so there's not any real
land to ensure that the returns are
voluntary that individuals are actually
going to be safe and there's a very
terrifying history of safe zones and so
finally just a few things about how we
as lawyers are trying to respond to the
threats that are facing our clients
first we're trying to be proactive and
aggressive with the response when we
knew that the first executive order was
going to be going into effect there were
leaked copies we immediately thought
that our clients could lose their status
in midair so we tried to organize
lawyers around the country to say be on
call if this goes into effect
be ready to assist and then when our
client was detained we were able with
clinic at Yale with the ACLU and the
National Immigration Law Center to
immediately file suit in federal court
which resulted in in order to release
anyone affected by the executive order
we've also pursued other litigation
based on the unconstitutionality of the
executive order we've tried to be
aggressive and proactive in terms of
data and tracking working with law firms
of others in the community with more
resources to be aggressive with
legislative advocacy and administrative
advocacy for things that are affecting
our client we've tried secondly to help
our clients who want to speak amplified
their voice until their story they're
really effective advocates in terms of
both traditional media and non
traditional media helping them you know
use public owned or public support a lot
of the public support and purports was
really effective and instrumental in
ensuring that there was a message that
this was not acceptable to the American
public and then third coordinating a lot
with allies bringing in non-traditional
allies the business community
educational community has been
incredibly affected by the executive
order which had a lot of help from local
governments and state governments that
aren't sometimes you know in our work in
the overseas refugee context you know
know that we're personally dealing with
that we've tried to reach out to them
and bring these communities to together
to coordinating so I look forward to
questions and discussion and thanks so
much was about the financial Africa
judgement
now ii was about the legal tracking of
you - m8 my turn for hopefully inviting
us a for this is a carbon inside mention
of first i'd like to recognize and thank
the organizers rotate the need for this
conference and i think you go to that
thing i try again
it's temperamental okay of this of this
meeting the enormity of the crisis
there's a number of people on the move
displaced from their homes facing great
great humanitarian need second the
changing nature of the crisis and the
changing in the humanitarian landscape
and the twenty was protect protracted
and long lasting crises including and
the interplay between nothing okay
between civil wars conflict and violent
humanitarian crisis and climate
pressures and other pressures of poverty
which placing just a confluence of
factors magnifying an exacerbating the
crisis and then despite some steps
forward and reformed the humanitarian
system still a crisis in the
international system systemic ability to
prevent and manage and respond I'd like
to do three things in a brief brief time
first recognize the linkages between
governance and politics and the
fragility of States and the humanitarian
crisis which are complex and have
secrets to summarize some of the
dynamics then address the question of
the need to address root causes where we
need to respond to the humanitarian
crisis at hand and be responsive how do
we seek to prevent anticipate and
respond and address root causes and then
second to examine some of the reforms
and the adequacy of the reforms to the
humanitarian system so first on the
linkages I think the so called fragile
States I think the term is inadequate
but there's now a body of research and
knowledge builder and that term the
linkages between these fragile states
and humanitarian crises need to be taken
into account in conditions where
governance is broken down the ability of
government to be able to prevent and
respond and anticipate and prevent and
minimize risk is much weaker the ability
to manage and respond to crises is much
lower and then because of the lack of
legitimacy lack of capability crises and
more conflict is more likely to break
out crises are more likely occur in
these contexts and of course every
country every region it is context
specific has a unique set of dynamics
but it is worth exploring some of those
those linkages
at a conference that Gutierrez cause
just before he left UNHCR he called a
summer to a retreat and said look the
humanitarian system is now at breaking
point and while they need to continue
this or fill those responsibilities he
argued that there needed to be a shift
including from the leadership of UNHCR I
think this is remarkable first time a
leader of UNHCR who really made that
call he said unless we shift more
attention to addressing the root causes
we're not going to be able to continue
at an international system to deal with
the increased flows alone so I found
that quite remarkable that somebody in
that position normally a head of UNHCR
will be just seeking to fulfill their
own mandate and brings more resources
expand the capabilities to respond but
you're saying oh we really need to shift
attention of course now he's the leader
of the United Nations as a whole so how
do we you know how so he seeks to
respond to that and his new leadership
position remains to be seen but how
might we think about this it was
actually echoed for me I met with a
young group of Yale College students
yesterday part of the International
Affairs Association and one of a young
woman who is a refugee herself said that
she could come to a similar conclusion
she said that she'd been a refugee or
her life she wants to work on these
issues but you know while that the need
to deal with refugee resettlement is
extremely important and that necessary
she felt that too that her efforts she
spent as she spoke for so many others in
the community unless they begin to
address the root causes and put to get
put in her words put back together the
building blocks of a world order where
these these crises will not continue to
break out seeing that that is an area
that that's not sufficient attention or
imagination and I think part of that is
because of the lack of confidence of the
international system you know to the
extent that these large-scale efforts in
both Iraq and Afghanistan has
taken enormous hundreds of billions of
resources and don't seem to her produce
results now they went humanitarian
responses they were security operations
to start with but had led to an enormous
lack of confidence that conflicts can be
resolved that countries can be rebuilt
so we've seen a shift in the pendulum
away from investing in the root causes
and solving conflicts to be a more
responsive mode and I think this loss of
confidence is perhaps somewhat misplaced
this one takes a step back the
international community over the last
decades and leaders of countries have
been able to resolve conflict they have
been able to cease it society to rebuild
they have been able to see conflict
settled and so on but at the moment is a
crisis of confidence as as possible or
can be done how might one think about it
in different ways my part of my
organizations work at the moment is to
look to take a step back and look at the
with nostra process we call the State of
the State what are the trends we're
seeing there are worrying trends we're
seeing in the countries that we call
Fred the international policy calls
fragile a trend that is actually getting
worse in many countries as a people
speak of a hollowing out of the state as
transnational criminal networks become
more intertwined with the public sector
people talk about these experienced
criminal patronage networks taking over
but it's a symptom of this as a
hollowing out of the face less
legitimacy less capability to deliver at
the same time in many countries we're
seeing a huge demographic increase
enormous benefit for the society in the
economy but it's going to put enormous
pressure on those already stretched and
limited public services leading towards
a greater crisis of service delivery and
legitimacy the trends and then leading
to the sort of getting into this vicious
cycle where legitimacy of the state the
lack of trust and the population
decreases and creating the condition to
outbreaks of violence inside the civil
wars the trends are not all bleak there
many trends going in a positive
direction I think it would bring your
attention to countries that have being
able to resolve a manage conflicts and
we
one of the trends that the UN is seeing
is that in the peacekeeping area it used
to be that countries would have a peace
agreement a peacekeeping mission and
then would graduate back to some degree
of normalcy what they're seeing now is
the increase in what we call these
protracted crises countries the
peacekeeping missions need to stay
longer conflict the cycle of violence
breaks out again to more countries are
joining peacekeeping missions but fewer
are graduating but back to there are
some positive trends as well a number of
countries still have been able to break
out of this cycle
so what Gutierrez was really calling for
and we think is really important is this
renewed focus on addressing root causes
what does that mean it means more
attention to prevention of conflict it
needs more attention and greater
granular detail understanding on how to
resolve conflicts how to build peace
agreements and then as a recent document
put out by the UN and attention to the
sustaining peace and investment in
understanding that countries don't
graduate from conflict to peace within a
two or three or five-year period
it really does take it sustained in most
cases of Staind effort over decades to
graduate and to build institutions to
create the conditions for sustained
peace this finding also endorsed by the
World Development Report of 2011 which
many of you may be familiar word which
is again said I think the authors of
that report said that they thought it
was the average time for a country to
graduate from conflict and violence to
sustainable peace was about 15 to 20
years I think the authors actually said
that they're probably the the real
length of time was much closer to three
or four or five decades but they didn't
want to put that in the report because
they said it would deter the
policymakers from the sustained action
necessary so and we're seeing I think
with Gutierrez leadership a great chance
that there will be more attention at
leadership levels on addressing root
causes but not to say this isn't an
immensely immensely complex and
challenging area and particularly
because in so many of these countries
the UN is a membership organization of
member states but in so many of these
countries they suffer from a sovereignty
gap or sovereignty power
these governments are taking in many
many cases not able or willing to
fulfill the basic sovereign
responsibilities to their own citizens
so ended a few reflections on the need
to reform the humanitarian system and
you know much-needed humanitarian summit
last year and a set of reforms announced
that agreed upon I think the question
and particularly for the academic
community there's an immense amount of
work to be done to scrutinize those
reforms were those the right reforms
announced and what reforms might be
needed what are the policy innovations
that are being carried out by
humanitarian actors around the world
which ones of them are working which
ones could be generalized which ones
could be incorporated more generally
into policy and standards and the large
organizations what kind of you know and
how does the humanitarian system in some
cases you know immediate response in
building parallel systems to respond to
a particular population are going to be
necessary and needed but when one has is
looking for tracted crises where
populations are displaced possibly for
decades how does one think about
incorporating them into the host
government and they're in their systems
and therefore how does the humanitarian
government want much more imaginative ly
with government systems even if those
government systems are imperfect they
exist the health systems exist to some
degree the public education systems
exist the infrastructure systems exist
so how does the humanitarian part system
partner both with government systems and
with private sector and in in the right
way now one example of a program that
did those from IRC was a key sort of
partner and innovator in this is a
program of giving block grants to
communities and letting them manage
their own resources and there are
innovations like this that can actually
be and I think in humanitarianism
talking about cost-effectiveness
it can seem cold-hearted and heart
in some cases but when one's looking at
the size of the populations really
looking at cost-effectiveness of
delivery over the longer term is
important so other ways that greater
efficiency better service delivery at
scale can can be built without building
that parallel systems in the lead-up to
the humanitarian summit I think a number
of the organizations that are involved
in delivery realized that if each of
them is to maintain essentially their
own parallel logisitics system the whole
system is costing multiples of what it
could if greater economies and
efficiencies of scale could be built so
I think in closing really a call to the
academic community to put their
imagination and their brains and their
research capabilities to work in
examining the organization and the
efficacy and the appropriateness and the
policy innovations that are taking place
and ones that could take place in the
humanitarian system thank you thank you
so audience I conclude that humanitarian
process is tough but here you we've been
offered a period of reflection and
analysis and dialogue so if we could
spend some 15 and 20 minutes just asking
the questions that are dear to our heart
perhaps the most difficult
Sonne provocative questions would be
really useful to hear both on a national
and international scale and I'm looking
now to you could you introduce yourself
sure Hannah Murphy in the School of
Medicine
this is a question maybe for Claire or
for Jodi the it seems to me one of the
things that is under addressed is a kind
of stakeholder analysis and helping
building the political case for for some
of this work the right when the world is
like most affected by refugees and
migration we see the politics of
countries turning towards nationalism
majority
and closing down when organizations
recognize that their individual
logistics systems cost multiples of what
they could if they cooperated but
there's a political imperative to be
showing that you're you're the one doing
good I'm doing good over here you go do
good over there so it like how do we as
academics balance the politics of these
for instance individual aid
organizations needing to get funds and
and and show that they're effective with
getting them to partner with other quote
unquote competing organizations to
achieve efficiencies and economies of
scale in question that last part in
terms of so I actually disagree that
that's happening my experience is and
I'm sure we can find examples where it
is happening but my experience is that
issues of coordination and collaboration
were very much in vogue in terms of the
critique the humanitarian critique about
you know like maybe you know five to ten
years ago but my experience is in a camp
setting there is you know enormous
division of labor and collaboration and
coordination it's not always efficient
so for example you can have a UN agency
taking on more of an implementation and
oversight role then perhaps its mandate
indicates and in that way they end up
duplicating what implementers do so that
kind of thing certainly happens but in
camp settings I think there is quite a
division of labor and then in non camp
setting
I would say the same that the prominent
issue that I have seen is not that
there's so much duplication and flag
planting and that that's the main cause
of inefficiency um to be honest I think
one of the main causes of inefficiency
is lack of data on cost we just don't
have a good way of costing out what it
costs to deliver results for people
across contexts so not only the cost of
producing a given well but also so cost
efficiency but also a cost effectiveness
of different ways of doing business so
the cost of decreasing order to be
caused by water point disease and then
it's very hard to make decisions about
how best to allocate resources and gain
efficiencies but I guess I don't
I guess I'm challenging the assumption
that the main that there's something
fundamental that there's flag planting
and competition and that's driving
inefficiency
I think I'd agree with you very much in
the CEM settings and non camp settings
our field researches show that it is
quite a sec you may not video new
program but it's quite a significant
problem and I think then you know what
it's really a question of incentives and
then the question of the kind of policy
coordination and budgeting and resource
allocation is is provided in some cases
that works very well in other cases it
works much less well I think and it
ultimately comes down to a question of
incentives and organization and
coordination one example where I think
innovation does work once one of the
program and I see a ship involved is
actually allocating the resources to the
community level and giving them the
decision rights and then NGOs can be
partners and in one particular case the
interiors of the facilitating partners
that they provide the technical
expertise but the actual decision on
whether it's a well that's needed or
school that's needed or emergency
sanitation
that's needed is actually made by the
community but on the basis which means
you know that's what they need most and
what they need next and what in what
order and so that's one mechanism that I
think very promising and a lot of
innovation has been made to ensure that
the refugee community and the IDB
community have incorporated into
decision making and a fair decision rate
rates are respected so I think that's
one mechanism another one is when you
know these those sort of big donors are
providing most of the funding can
actually perform the coordination one
example of this is in the Health System
an example I know what was happening is
there were in some villages there were
five NGOs in the next town we're not and
so there's bunching of and you know do
you blame the NGOs no because they
didn't have the data and the evidence of
where the needs were and so what the
three major donors of the country
coordinated amongst themselves agreed on
a set of service standards and then
contracted out the NGOs province by
province to fulfill to a certain
standard so those are sorting mechanism
so those are two examples of the kind of
mechanisms that I think have been able
to deal and there's a lot of innovation
at space there are still some places
where it's not happening
thank you
dr. Karen acara you had a question
any what I'm wondering where to start
Julia I think you're way more positive
about the world humanitarian summit then
I am I think all right but it seems more
positive because you know we had the
largest gathering of humanitarian
agencies and workers and civil society
organization come to Istanbul bang in
the middle of what was the biggest
refugee crisis and some of the biggest
conflict since the 1990s where we had
the largest number of civil conflicts at
any point in time and if you look at the
outcomes there's no mention about the
refugee crisis there's no mention about
humanitarian action in conflict where
all of the soft stuff which we agree on
anyways yes
localization is important
we need to direct more funding to local
agencies all of those are soft issues I
think there is general agreement that
this needs to happen but none of the big
issues were tackled and dealt with and I
prolly agree with what the non
secretary-general Guterres said about
you know we have to start thinking about
the root causes but there does not seem
to be any willingness among the you know
the Security Council members or others
to really sit down and address on these
problems so I don't know asks
humanitarian agencies and less academic
you know from universities how we can
actually begin to tinker and you laid
out some areas multilateralism how do we
start thinking about a new world order
because I think and it has tied up with
political economic models that we
subscribe to today how do we start
beginning about beginning to think about
these things and how can we influence
policymakers those in DC and and you
know the I've been a humanitarian worker
for 20 years the more I travel the more
I'm convinced that policies made in DC
and Brussels have way more influence on
the lives of people in these countries
than policies that they make themselves
perhaps so how do we start going down
that road to sort of bringing about
change I know there's a big question
million-dollar question but I'd love to
hear your thoughts which I knew the
answer that is that indeed is the you
know that is the question I mean the
that the only like the only concept that
seems to have come up over and over
again that resonates in terms of
diagnosis is lack of accountability or
the concept of accountability and but I
don't yeah again I don't have a good and
sir I think you're absolutely right that
there isn't a lot that came out of the
world humanitarian summit I think one of
the most promising set of parameters or
statements was represented by the grand
bargain which for those of you who don't
know resulted from a high-level panel
talking essentially about the financing
of aid and that really spoke to this
notion of the quality of the money the
lack of long-term planning the lack of
partnership between development and
humanitarian donors and the bind that
that system puts governments in
primarily governments in those countries
in in terms of being able to actually
make change happen I think that was a
very well-written articulate set of
documents and it stuck out because
everything about the world humanitarian
summit was the opposite but I know
firsthand because IRC has stayed
involved that what happened after that
was a series of kind of ongoing
discussions without leadership in terms
of who's going to take this forward and
who is going to be accountable for
fulfilling those commitments
even the important organization I was
hoping maybe you could do a little bit
of prognostication about what's going to
happen with these executive orders you
know right now are any refugees getting
into the US and what do you think you
know the outcome is going to be do you
think that our president is going to
just give up on the strategy we've seen
an example with the Affordable Care Act
you did kind of give up on that you know
is this just political sort of you know
a display that is eventually going to be
kind of forgotten I'd love to hear your
thoughts about you know at the end of
this year what do you predict is going
to be the situation well right now the
executive orders are being challenged in
court and so the Fourth Circuit is going
to hear on bonk which means the entire
set of judges of the Fourth Circuit
which is sort of an exceptional step
because it hasn't yet been decided by a
smaller panel and I think the
expectation is that it you know will
likely go to the Supreme Court either
through the Fourth Circuit which is
where I reps cases along with with other
with other plaintiffs and then for the
Ninth Circuit which is where the state
of Hawaii has brought its litigation
there and and so I mean I think we're
confident that this is unconstitutional
that there are lots of statements
showing the discriminatory animus and
discriminatory effect of the of the
executive order I mean I think the other
concern that we have is that it is just
there's a clear signal from the
administration you know sort of
involving the discretion of officers at
airports I mean we've had clients that
we've done since 2008 we've helped
special immigrant visa holders who've
interpreted for US forces for years and
we had never seen someone with a valid
visa that it for years get stopped with
regular deportation and airport and this
is happening after the orders have been
enjoying so this is some other basis and
so
there is some type of Correction Airi
decision we challenged someone in Afghan
at LAX and his family is was going to be
deported back to Afghanistan and other
Newark is still detained and so these
are you know sort of just individual
cases that we work on but the broader
idea is that there is a tremendous
amount of discretion at oversees in the
people who are deciding pieces and the
people who are letting individuals to
the country and so we're concerned that
even if you have you know the first
executive order which was rescinded
because it was so awful the second which
according to the president is
essentially the same and you know we say
is the same animus and even if that's
found unconstitutional your work we're
also worried that in there will be
various discriminatory practices both in
practice form and then also by the
pulsing sort of policy form with the
administration but at a lower
administrative level and then also
practices by individuals that are you
know given a lot of discretion and to do
this so that I think that's our concern
I can add from from s oh I know this
number offhand because of a recent
conversation that I think we are seeing
up to 900 people at week coming in and
having advocated and been involved in
the executive order also an IRC is very
much in the mix but the difference over
the weeks between the numbers kind of
stayed and then coming in has been quite
significant because if we teach a course
here on child health and development in
context of sustainable development goals
formally UNICEF I wanted to go back to
the concerns that you raised earlier in
your presentation about the increasing
erosion of human humanitarian space and
linked that to the fact that over the
years what seems to be quite evident is
also the increasing intensity of human
rights crisis and abuses in combination
with humanitarian the classically
manatorian situations and I wonder again
a case of prognostication what what
direction should the academia and the
general community take in terms of
fighting harder to uphold human rights
as the framework for the basic
principles on which all of the
humanitarian community's work is based
in this presentation if in fact there is
value to commit or recommit to human
rights children's rights and
international humanitarian law I
the basis for our argument and they're
making the case on behalf of refugees on
behalf of refugee children etc
wouldn't that be a central premise for
the advocacy for the policy work for
some of the studies the empirical
studies that need to emerge in other to
reverse this tendency that I worry that
as the space constructs we also see an
increasing number of of humanitarian
abuses humanitarian crisis and yet those
principles are the only ones we have
that would give us a handle so
revisiting the situation I think we
shouldn't let go we've got to find a way
of ensuring that we build on that and
perhaps through a stronger advocacy on
human rights child rights and human care
internet international humanitarian law
we might be able to at least hold the
line I wonder what your perspective
so I I wish that were the case I think
the two questions I would ask you are to
whom should we be advocating and and who
would be committing because I think the
very reality is that the root causes of
conflict the the fragility and lack of
good governance that we see and the
confluence of poverty and suffering and
the hold that non-state and warring
parties can have on a society would say
that that that system that we're
observing right now is completely
disconnected and doesn't care about
whether or not we're talking about
international humanitarian law or human
rights regimes so I think to be quite
provocative I think that that's in part
why we continue to lament the crises
that we're seeing is we keep harkening
back to these principles that are
clearly not operating
you know the cornerstone of humanitarian
action is protection and there's no
doubt in any country in the world that
where people are suffering like this
they're not protected so I don't really
know what that would do except maybe
make us feel better or make us feel more
connected to you know our own values my
perspective is that you know this level
of literacy general knowledge and
awareness in the local communities which
are supposed to benefit from these
actions he included humanitarian action
need to be brought up to a level at
which people can demand accountability
by themselves it doesn't have to be an
international rescue
committee your unit says that's pushing
so I think the first point is what can
be done to generalize the knowledge
raise awareness and increase the level
of literacy on these issues at the level
of ordinary people and make them part of
the equation the second is that I think
clearly governments have the primary
responsibility for protection and so we
advocate to them and hold their feet to
the fire and the United States has still
not ratified the Convention on the
Rights of the Child and you know their
vests to work to be done the u.s.
signals the rest of the world when there
are cuts in humanitarian and domestic
social services etc it sends a signal
across the landscape to other countries
that you know in relief you know this is
it's the trend today and other countries
will follow suit and so there is a case
to be made in my mind to try and bring
these stakeholders the key stakeholders
around and push harder for I can't
imagine a world in which we abandoned
the humanitarian rights and the human
rights children's rights imperatives
that have driven our work after now
we've got to hold the line I think we
can't really let go since
being in a conference of donors in in
London and having the what somebody was
referred to me yesterday as the brochure
talk about empowerment and partnerships
and whatever and then and then I said a
little bit about the same thing and he
looked like Oh human rights and health
rights are just aspirational and I
nearly killed that person in a sense
that I think aspirational is really
important to be able to regional is
really important because some of us have
to lift on those after the mark in the
mud and to hold on to that
that's why I've started today with with
values slowly getting depressed during
the morning but having lunch and promise
you to rebuild a better future starting
at 3 but I do think that that framework
of rights even though it is sometimes
unimplemented is still aspirational in
the best sense that ambition can take us
I think if I can add an underscore very
much on especially on the human rights
certain it's the basis of the UN
declaration in the UN Charter and I do
agree that there's a immense opportunity
needs a greater public education
especially civic citizens have greater
awareness of their basic rights
recognized under the Charter and
especially when it comes to the
government the national government to
bear Duty bearers a lot more can be done
in advocacy in international law and
international politics and arena like
the UN and international relations to
reiterate those fundamental duties of
governments to meet to protect the human
rights of their own citizens and hold
them to accountable and I would argue
for something you know who've got the
responsibility to protect regime and
that's you know highly debated as to how
effective it is but even to expand that
that you know the government's have not
only the duty to respect to protect
against awful crimes but they have the
responsibility to meet the citizens
basic needs
and one more question thank you all for
being here I my name is Steven medica
and I run an up a non-profit
international consortium here and in New
Haven working with students pretty much
all over the world but concentrating now
in Europe in the United States my
question is this is it's it's more in
politics which unfortunately intrudes
everything we do and I'm wondering each
of your about each of your opinions
regarding Turkey and the safe third
country concept and why you as
representatives of international human
rights organizations haven't raised more
of a clamor about the fact that Turkey
is obviously not a safe third country
and this is at the core of the agreement
last year March 18th March 20th that
allows European countries to I'd use the
word export but transport refugees from
them from Europe to Turkey and it's
obviously a total non-starter so I'm
wondering why you haven't talked about
this I know politically it would be
horrible but your international human
rights organizations and it seems to me
it's your responsibility to bring this
to the public's attention so thank you
very much
yeah I mean I it's extremely concerning
and and although I rap is we're a really
small organization sort of a mandate
around the work that we do in terms of
resettlement and bringing people to
safety I know that Human Rights Watch
Amnesty have both been I believe have
spoken that you know this is not
acceptable that it's not a safe third
country that refugees can't be returned
from from European countries and I think
that the you know the similar to the
safe zones issue and the other concerns
of both limiting aid in countries of
first refuge and essentially you know
forcing refugees to return by you know
pushing them back towards the the harm
that they face of this continual
pushback is something that we we have
raised I mean it involves you know I
know the organizations that are helping
refugees in Turkey are also really
concerned about the the system there and
yeah I mean it's a good it's a fair
point I just make quick follow-up so my
question is this why hasn't a case been
brought at Strasbourg why haven't any
one's really done anything except to say
oh that's terrible
and I'm not denigrating what your
response but it seems to me that
politicians only only respect legal
action and you all as representatives of
human rights agencies are the ones are
the logical ones to to bring an action
like this and even though I understand
that that would not make you exactly
most favorite person people in Turkey
but I'm just wondering why haven't you
done something specific instead of just
saying it's terrible well I mean no I
mean I think that that's exactly what
has to happen which is that challenging
a return to
through the European Court of Human
Rights which is the venue where you
would exhaust your domestic remedies and
then bring it there I mean I can't
personally other than the fact that
that's not you know our you know
particular work I can't really you know
speak to the sort of overall strategy
may I add to that
Catherine Toki is not really the bad guy
here even though I have reservations
about the current president I think as
far as refugees are concerned Tech has
done remarkably well hosting you know
all close to three million refugees
there are several organizations working
in Europe challenging some of the
European Union policies the eu-turkey
deal and especially now the even more
dangerous
EU Libya deal that they're working on so
there are agencies in Europe working on
challenging some of these I mean really
dangerous sort of agreements that
European Union is trying to reach with
these countries so we find ourselves a
little sticky situation where we have
two sinks smart and smart and think hard
about ways forward but this will be the
afternoon session on rebuilding I have
promised you it's time for lunch we
wanted an extended period of lunch where
you can restore your energy and talk to
each other and I hope that you come back
for this afternoon which includes three
kind of provocative sessions and
creative sessions until the wrap-up at
4:30
thank you very much for staying this
long and if you don't mind a round of
applause for my friends up here
[Music]